welcome everyone to this panel
discussion on the very timely topic
political truth and the value of trust
my name is Karen possession I will be
moderating this conversation I'm the
political editor in chief of Aftonbladet
and I'm very honored to have with me
this extremely distinct distinguished
panel joseph stiglitz of course one of
America's most prominent public
intellectuals Nobel laureate in
economics thinker right there all of the
above I'm sure most of you know him
general Hayden General Michael Hayden
and most of you I think I've heard him
during the day
former director of the NSA and the CIA
and now also security analyst for CNN
right yes and they inept affection right
their academic and my favorite title in
the world
techno sociologist and thinker about the
Internet and as I said political truths
and the value of trust I start talking
and I want to start out with two quotes
by two politicians and one of one is by
the former American president Barack
Obama who said that if the people cannot
trust their government to do the job for
which it exists to protect them and to
promote their common welfare all else is
lost so Trust is central and then we
have a politician with a different
background I trust no one not even
myself it's startling this is the range
we're talking about I want to ask all of
you this question what is the value of
trusts in democratic societies and what
happens when it disappears professor
professor Stiglitz do you want to start
well I think I think Trust is obviously
absolutely essential
maybe I should begin by thinking about
it you know
what is the role of trust in markets in
the economy because we often think about
markets based on contracts demanding
supply we don't talk about trust but
when you realize that every day we have
relations with other people that are not
contractually defined and if we had to
go to court every time we had a
difference our whole economic system
would break down so that in fact Trust
is ironically essential for a market
economy the example where that broke
down was in 2008 when we had a financial
crisis no bank would trust any other
bank because they knew how bad they were
and how they were lying so they had
every reason not to trust everybody else
and once they didn't trust they wouldn't
lend to anybody else and when they
didn't lend to anybody else the whole
financial system collapsed so that's a
sort of a dramatic illustration of the
role of trust in the functioning of our
society but it happens pervasively well
the same thing is true in our democracy
and we're going through you might say
intro in the United States an
interesting experiment nobody I should
say nobody almost nobody trusts anything
that the president says but they do
trust our institutions so the president
makes utterances all the time as if he
expects it has to have any truth value
that somebody would but everybody knows
that you know he's will lies when it's
convenient so it has no probative value
it if no it wouldn't stand up so yet he
makes these statements but where our
society is continuing to function is
that we have trust in a whole set of
other institutions the fact that he is
engaged in an assault on these
institutions as you described earlier
shows that he
recognizes the importance of these other
institutions and so you know if you
wanted a nightmare of scenario to ask
what would our how would our democracy
function if these other institutions
weren't there you know I can't conceive
of what that you know it is a nightmare
scenario and and so far at least I think
we're lucky that these institutions and
there are some others like the
importance of the civil service which is
a whole you know we often demonize it as
the bureaucracy but the function of that
beot bureaucracy is to make sure that
the rules the laws and regulations are
enforced and our knowledge that we've
accumulated about how that they work is
perpetuated and he's trying to do what
he can to to destroy that you see it
most dramatically in the State
Department but it's elsewhere in our
government so you know for now we can be
thankful that we have this residual of
trust but it is obviously a real source
of worry what will happen if it gets
weaker so that's going from the
functioning of the market economy and
the transaction costs basically and also
the trusting in governmental
institutions general Hayden what's your
what is the value I'll get back to you
and your specific background and trust
but but can you elaborate on this
question the value of trust for
democracy specifically in general terms
second all that said in addition to the
assault on the Free Press fake news and
and so on there is a broad generalized
thrust against the permanent government
is the phrase I use as an
anti-democratic deep state all right
it's actually working very very hard
very very secretly
to overturn the results of the election
or if not the results of the election
the intent of the people who elected
President Trump and then that that's it
that's a storyline that's a narrative
that permeates discussion about this
back home
I I have a specific issue with trust in
government
with my own professional background
because trust in the intelligence
community has been up and down over the
past ten or ten or fifteen years
weapons of mass destruction a clear
error all right
not not a sin not a crime and no gun to
our head we just got it wrong and so the
problem we have as an institution is
that the dialogue about intelligence is
often confused with the kinds of
certainty that one might get from
science or from a court of law and what
I'm fond of saying is that we're we're
not designed not that we don't mind
getting there not that we would not work
hard to get to this point but the
institution is not designed to get to
the point of certainty that we get to in
a court of law beyond all reasonable
doubt because in in in the realm within
which we work waiting to get to beyond
all reasonable doubt simply means you
lose that you've lost all advantage that
your nation is being acted on where
rather than acting so so the purpose of
intelligence is actually to enable
action even in the face of lingering
doubt there the question of trust really
becomes very very important and so so if
we have created circumstances and
frankly you mentioned everything the
president says can be held up to the
light and and might actually be a lie
my great fear is that the American
intelligence community will tell him
something if you'll be ambiguous because
that's what we do but we'll do it to the
degree we can substantiate high
confidence and in this case maybe the
President believes us but nobody
believes him and I'm serious and when he
when he goes to your capitals to say we
got to go do this are you with me
and there maybe I'll get back to you
as the strongest response and it's based
upon trust and again back to the
bloodline back to the institution
because we will probably never be able
to give him a case in which the response
the answer the way forward is so
intuitively obvious that some level of
faith or trust is not required so they
never fix it I want to continue this
conversation about I want to add an
aspect because we seem to get stuck I
mean there's so much going on right now
and Trump is this trauma I mean not just
for the US but for the globe and the
entire globe but I also the discussion
of trust isn't new there was a we talked
about this even before Trump got elected
so I also want to ask you what is the
role of trust but also how did we get
here and how did we lose it
that's a great question earlier on
general Hayden was talking about how the
president seems to live in the eternal
now and Maggie Haberman who's the New
York Times columnist also was talking
about that I think it's really important
as important that it is to try to figure
out how to survive this moment how did
we get here
and I think lack of accountability and
sort of questioning of the failures of
our existing institutions that we need
right now right we need them right now
has really helped us get here so start
with say the New York Times right I
write for the New York Times it's a
great paper it's that amazing
investigations but it's roll up to the
Iraq war widget you just brought up was
a huge failure it was a failure in
reporting it was a failure in all sorts
of ways and I believe one person perhaps
lost their job over that and it hasn't
really been reckoned with Wow the u.s.
press got there in the 2016 election
u.s. press was pretty I would say again
I think it's very important to protect
the New York Times kind of institutions
but its conduct up to the election
in terms of how it covered candidate
Trump and candidate Hillary Clinton how
it responded to say the WikiLeaks thinks
I think it failed badly we don't discuss
it I criticize Facebook and Google all
the time that's my topic we don't
discuss mainstream media and their
failures and how we got there I think
2008 the global crisis was a major
saying in the United States about one in
five adult men either lost their job or
came close to losing their job there's a
way in which the global economy is
failing many ordinary people in very
severe ways as helpful as it may be to
the global middle class we don't discuss
it
it took Donald Trump to bring some of
this up I want to go back to the Iraq
war which seems to be the thing that
never gets discussed in the sort of the
public sphere as much in that it was
terribly destructive to the region it
was wrong in many ways as he said the
weapons of mass destruction part turned
out to be not true and there has never
been full accounting for what that meant
there has never been full accounting for
everything that came after it there's
never never been full accounting for
there's been this loss of institutional
trust I think that goes back to decades
of our institutions that I defend that
I'm part of that here we are sitting
we're part of that we failed in
fundamental ways structural ways we fail
to be responsibly failed to be an
unaccountable well we get something
wrong we're like oh we just got
something wrong and we move on
whereas lives are destroyed in large
numbers so I think the moment we're
facing right now
is that we have these weaknesses and
dangerous currents are coming through
those weaknesses and I believe we're at
a very dangerous moment globally but I
feel like we're almost lucky that the in
the case the u.s. we have a reality TV
star that got elected you know we can
probably survive this moment because we
have institutions but if we do not fix
I think accountability transparency
gaining trust how do we do right by the
people in a way that makes sense
for the people I feel like we're just
gonna live through this again and again
what's more dangerous once coming again
and I think we should really be
discussing that as much as discussing
you know what does Donald Trump get
wrong so what you're saying is that this
moment is a result of something and of
course I'm going to give the word to
professor Stiglitz who has been studying
the connection between trust and
economic inequality and kind of the
macro fundamentals driving us towards
this maybe I don't know
yeah and that title of the session was
political truths and one of the reasons
that I think there's been the loss of
trust is that for a third of a century
we've had political leaders who said
that globalization dances and Technology
were going to lead everybody to be
better off and so you you you had a
strong agenda and even under Obama they
were saying TPP was going to new trade
agreement with across the Pacific was
going to increase have enormous benefits
and what people were experiencing was
just the opposite and I think a critical
point as mentioned was the 2008 prices
and why was critical was it was at that
moment that you saw that things had not
worked out well we are not created a
financial system that was stable that
would benefit everybody the banks were
engaged in predatory lending and then
we've saw market manipulation you know a
whole set of abuses and two things
happen
the bankers walked off with huge bonuses
ordinary Americans lost their homes
their jobs and there was no
accountability much less accountability
than happened after the much smaller
crisis the S&L crisis that nobody
remembers now in
and night 19 in the 1989 so there's a
sense that the system does it it has no
system of accountability and then in one
sense making it one sense worse is we
had a president previous president got
elected on a platform of change you
could believe in and continued with the
same economics team that had brought on
the crisis in the first place and so you
seem to have a political system that was
not accountable that was lying if you
were going to and I don't know if we you
know they were clearly over settling
globalization they were over selling and
when just to highlight one more little
aspect of the ironing when the
government itself came and evaluated how
much would TPP this Agreement that was
supposed to be the largest trade
agreement ever the government came and
evaluated and set the net effect on our
growth over when it was fully
implemented in 15 years was 0.15 percent
of GDP an independent evaluator said
that was a gross exaggeration with
accent is there's something else going
on in this agenda you've just made this
the biggest thing ever and it's nothing
what are you doing
and that's fixed in two you might say a
conspiracy theory but this is all about
is corporate power and it was all about
it wasn't that workers wages going down
was collateral damage in the way that's
often happened this was the main show it
was really to weaken workers bargaining
power and increase inequality so what
you're saying if I understand you
correctly is that the collapse of trust
happened before and Trump is the effect
of the collapse of trust because if
people don't believe in politics any
more than they might just as well you
know elect someone who's least
entertaining well he he is the
consequence of
could trust but the damage that he's
done is enormous so you know you've gone
down it was going down but what's
happening since then is is a precipitous
fall so no I I think you have to really
blame him but in a way he took advantage
of what would of a decline in trust and
it's taken a bad problem and made it
infinitely worse but do you think he
would have been would he have been
elected if the levels of trust in
politics had been higher I know I don't
think it would have been elected I think
he here's the consequence of our
failures both both political parties ran
a primal scream to be the president the
United States all right the Democrats
were wired in such a way that the party
could prevent that person from becoming
the nominee Republicans could not that
both were running a primal scream so um
you have been talking about this but I
want to stay I want to dig into this
question because it really comes back to
the former than generation or the last
two generations of politicians of public
officials I guess your generation where
did you go like boy where did you go
wrong
I'd say accountability is at the heart
of it I think people feel like they lost
sovereignty hmm I feel like you know the
2008 crisis happens and everybody walks
away the Iraq war happens destroys both
American and Iraqi lives and the region
everybody walks away when the
establishment when the people in power
make mistakes we walk away in ways that
I think the people are affected by do
not walk away and then in places where
they vote they're like vote for the
person who's promising to burn it down
in places where there's no vote I think
they join extremist groups a June
terrorism I think there's a way in which
we are not providing people with the
world in which that they don't think
everything is stacked against them and
the ways in which they could win are
peaceful and that they are
open avenues to them a and I'm not
seeing this to exculpate anybody's bad
decisions art everybody's responsible
for their own moral decisions the people
who make those wrong decisions they're
responsible for them Trump is
responsible for himself but I feel like
how do we set up structure so that when
you look at the world you don't think
the people in power whatever they do
they get away with it and I think that's
a whole big thing that we have to face
as much as I agree with the fact that we
are facing a dangerous moment right now
- I think one has to realize I think
many of the people who were acting in
this period over the last 30 years that
set up these problems we're acting in
good faith I I think they there was a
prevalent ideology both in Europe and
America here you referred often to his
neoliberalism it permeated both parties
in the United States there were
dissonant voices but they were a a small
minority and I it you know like any
ideology it it becomes very strong and
so when you raised arguments like Oh
economic science economic theory
predicts that unskilled workers are
we're going to be made worse off the
response is oh somehow and that was as
the economy grows everybody is going to
be better off there's going to be
trickle-down economics and it was just
an article of faith
no no structure but it was an article of
faith felt as I say by a lot of goodwill
people but also a lot of people who saw
it in their self-interest and it was
that combination of corporate interests
and an ideology that work together that
made this a a prevalent view with and
then in the absence of accountability
means that a system that you know
actually lies from authority lies in the
sense that they made projections and
those
dings did come through nobody was held
accountable and I think that really
contributes to to the weakening of trust
this is all true unarguable but I also
there's a structural issue that's
created the lack of responsiveness from
the government over the last 10 20 or 30
years and at the risk of sounding less
like an American intelligence officer
and more like a political science
professor we we have allowed our
electoral districts in our states to be
gerrymandered and it happens every
decade in in sequence with our census
and the Republicans are a little more
guilty of this than the Democrats but in
essence we get to redraw our electoral
districts and and what the parties have
done has to is to redraw the districts
so that almost none of them are
competitive that this will be a
Republican district this will be a
democratic districts so that the general
election that outcome is for ordained
it's going to go either red or blue the
only election that matters is the
primary who's going to be the Republican
nominee who's going to be the Democrat
nominee and that dynamic has as the
dynamic of pulling the representative
further to the corner so that
Republicans become more red more
conservative over time Democrats more
blue more liberal over time vacating the
center space and so what we now have
which makes us unresponsive our body of
folks in the Congress with no personal
guilt all right but just the reality of
how this works who are very red and very
blue and see everything through the
Wellness the goodness the advantage for
the party rather than to the nation so
to get to the bottom line there are no
body of facts that Bob Mahler
will uncover that will cause a
republican-controlled House of
Representatives to draw up articles of
impeachment on Donald Trump period so
but here's the thing though there's lack
of
bad faith is often true sometimes not
sometimes it's just self-interest right
the bankers they were just making a lot
of money that's why you build
institutions to protect people from
believing they're doing the right thing
because everybody who does the wrong
thing or like not everybody but a lot of
times people do wrong things telling
themselves I'm doing the right thing
right that's the value of institutions
and I feel like a lot of our
institutions have done things where
people that each love will feel like I
this is what I have to do and then they
cross those lines and then we lose trust
in the institutions themselves so how do
we build that so let's talk come back to
the now and talk about the present
moment and I want to ask you is in up
because you're an expert on the Internet
and this new information infrastructure
that we're living with I'm thinking of
the big platform companies Facebook and
Google and we've been talking about this
today social media do they promote trust
or do they undermine it and how should
we think about this layer of technology
that we have to interact with each other
through so the current social media
environment they don't have trust
necessarily as a goal even like so if
our old-style institutions failed from
you know providing the truth in fact to
us as as the Iraq war example I just
gave the current ones they just want
your attention they just want your
attention to sell to the advertisers for
them New York Times Guardian News which
is a fake newspaper it doesn't really
matter as long as they got your eyeballs
and they got your data and they're
selling it to the advertisers which is a
very pernicious development on top of
all of this so we already had these
failing institutions that were failing
from at least ethos we could defend we
had lack of accountability for them and
I include the press I include the
Academy which I'm part of I include the
intelligence services I include the US
government we all failed from what we
should have been and now you got these
things they're not even failing from
that right they all they care about is
are you clicking are you there
this combination is such a dangerous
moment where you have this is kind of
reminds me like I'm obsessed with the
period between World War 1 and World War
2 where you have the sort of failing
trust and institution and new means of
propaganda in that case film right the
triumph of the world kind of thing
rising at the same time and demagogues
going through that and I think we're
pretty similar in a lot of the dynamics
yeah yes
can I just I know you can I just give
you a question
a Don a question to that because many
people make that comparison but what we
don't have today is an economic crisis
we don't have hyperinflation we don't
have we have an ideally sorry very
luckily very very luckily but at the
same time there is this level of rage
that is just just this seems to be like
a mismatch between the level of rage and
the actual macro fundamental sometimes
do you agree with that or is it
inequality or stakes I think we do have
a crisis yes because the inequality is
so bad
you know life expectancy in the United
States on average is in decline and if
you look at those groups white males say
who are not college educated their life
expectancy is under marked decline an X
and it's from diseases of despair things
like suicide drug overdose alcoholism
and the only other time I've seen
something like that and the data is when
the Soviet Union collapsed in Russia and
there was a complete dissolution of
society and life expectancy goes down so
we have a symptom in the United States
of something that is very that is
troublesome you can have a problem if
there's a marked discrepancy between
expectations and reality and fear and
people looking around you know
so how many people lost their jobs how
many people lost their homes there is a
real sense of fear but I wanted to go
back and answer the question the way in
which I see the the the Facebook for
instance contributing to the lack of
trust really fixed in with what you said
which is that it reinforces echo
chambers because you get you want clicks
and the way the clicks go you have like
and I you know and and so if you're
interacting a lot they want news you
know they like things that trend do they
like people to interact and that creates
exactly the kind of framework that exact
you know takes off you you have a more
divided society that sees things in very
different ways so if if you have the two
parties were seeing the truth whatever
it in such different light there is no
way that you can have trust in our
institutions because whatever the
government does the other group will say
it's wrong the facts are not there if at
this point you know the United States is
the only country in which there are very
large numbers of climate deniers and you
know and and if the government does
anything they'll say the climate deniers
are saying it's been taken over by a
bunch of liberals or and if they don't
the other group gets angry so as an area
where there is an objective truth but
our system has moved so far away from
that truth that you have a majority of
one of the political party is not
believing in climate science and so so
strongly one of the ironies is normally
you if you if you ask are more educated
people more likely to believe in
climate change almost everywhere you
would say yes more educated people
understand in the United States that's
not true why is that because on average
more educated people belong to the
Republican Party and they're well theory
ideological paper rather than exactly so
the its ideological driven and so you
get this inverse correlation which is
very strong but sort of highlights the
the challenge that we have in restoring
trust so we have the macro fundamental
fundamentals which doesn't look so good
especially in the US we have this new
layer of technology that is not making
things better to say the list and so and
we have this moment I'm interested in
the question how we should act what's
the responsibility of civil servants of
US citizens and general Hayden with your
background and thinking about the
community that you have been a part of
what can the intelligence community for
example do if your country has a leader
that won't accept facts for example what
is your responsibility will you continue
working and delivering facts or should
you give facts to the to the pub should
you deliver the facts to the public what
do you do it wonderful question so if
you recall what I said this morning
I mean rarely do we go in there with a
syllogism and where the outcome is
obvious and and preordained you set the
left and the right hand boundaries so to
a first order there's space here in
which other legitimate factors can play
value ideology priority and so on
alright but but you do have an ethical
obligation to say something to somebody
when the policy is outside the bounds
and in effect you've either divided by
zero over here and this can't work or
you've made the assumption you can make
water go uphill over here and that's not
going to work either you know this is a
failing policy so you hold the debate
within the executive
I have never personally had to go ahead
and push the plunger so to speak and
blow something up the closest I came was
the was the President Bush's decision
for the surge in 2006 early 2007 and in
which we sent five combat brigades to
make right what had gone badly wrong in
Baghdad our assumption was you put those
five professional non-sectarian brigades
of combat power in the city you you're
gonna push the violence down you're
gonna achieve that objective but we
actually said to the president but
that's not your big plan your big plan
is to create space for the Iraqi Prime
Minister Nouri al-maliki
to actually become the prime minister of
Iraq rather than of Dawa party and the
Shia and we made it very clear that is
not a high probability shot all right if
he will have to govern beyond his life
experience and for lots of reasons and
we articulated it so there we are and
the president says got it
send the five brigades and so that
decision to my mind was kind of about
here now the president insisted on
having a personal video teleconference
with the prime minister of Iraq every
week for the rest of his administration
in which he was trying to coach and
mentor so that's that's been my
experience all right you don't determine
you do affect if you're out here and you
know what's going to fail it's really
hard one one path forward is to talk to
the other political branch of government
we're also beholding and in our system
far more so than a parliamentary system
you you can make things known to another
co-equal competing branch of government
so that's one and then you know in an
emergency break glass it's going public
which again as I try to suggest earlier
today breaks the norms of the profession
by saying things publicly that are
genuine
and and correctly classified and and so
it creates it creates a horrific dilemma
one other point I don't know I'm going
too long here
traditionally presidents run the things
they say by the Intel community you get
a look at certainly prepared remarks and
you get to say you may say that if you
want but if asked we can't back it up
which for most presidents is plenty of
reason enough to drop it out of the
speech I see so many things in president
Trump's commentary but I can't believe
that that process is is ongoing and so I
think what the leadership is just doing
the best they can within the
circumstances they find themselves and
are not yet ready to break glass because
they haven't gotten to that position
okay so we have three great minds here
and we have a problem
and we need to fix it right we we have a
collapse of trust we have new
information infrastructure we have
macroeconomic problems and we have this
collapse to trust in political
leadership what should we do then
do you wanna well
all right in 30 seconds here's the
answer well I'm gonna just say one
little thing and then I'll get to the
answer is that I think I keep going back
to the accountability thing something
something I worry about a lot is
terrorism because these platforms have
been great for extremist content these
platforms Isis has been recruiting
through this I'm an anti censorship
person my whole life and I wrote one of
the first op eds calling for Facebook
and Twitter to kick them off the
platform so I because I don't think it's
a free speech issue I think Goods us so
I'm just something I worry about all the
time and when I hear sort of this
discussion of free - what you just said
on like the search thing right this is
something that the current situation in
Middle East is fueling enormous amount
of terrorism but one of the things we
still haven't dealt with and how to move
forward is that we broke our own norms
in that war right we broke our norms it
came public
u.s. tortured detainees and we've not
dealt with it
trust me that comes up every day in the
Middle East that comes up all the time
now it's a what about ISM there's so
much more going on there but there are
ways in which I think we haven't dealt
with how we broke our norms and why and
how do we move forward from there that I
think is fueling a lot of these big
issues that we kind of keep dancing
around so before we go forward with
here's my thirty second answer I feel
like the people who've been in power the
past 20-30 years we have to sort of have
these really frank conversations about
accountability and how do we move on the
second thing is we have to also defend
these faulty institutions and rebuild
them for the 21st century so that we
have cultural antibodies institutional
antibodies we have ways of defending
truths and facts but I don't think we
can do it if we ignore what happens
since then which makes it really tricky
I wish we had this conversation five
years ago ten years ago twenty years ago
on you know a lot of things in that the
simultaneous thing is that we build our
new institutions to this new world but
we also sort of sit down and say how did
we fail from our norms that keep us
strong that makes us special that are
the ones that are worth defending and
then we move forward general Hayden I'm
gonna ask you maybe this is unfair but I
I'll ask you this because I think many
people outside of the US wonder about
how how can you let him keep on for this
long like why is no one stopping him on
the you know within the Republican Party
where are they you talk so much about
checks and balances in your political
system but where why aren't keep
standing up and making why sandy
critique from his Oh from the Republican
Party louder yeah and you talked about
gerrymandering and polarization and
that's of course a big part of it but
there seems to be something lacking in
terms of I don't know courage or
values your shirt but if bitter sunny
not for and maybe this is not fair but
just as a you said it you wanted to be a
particular science professor so so it's
been uneven and I share disappointment
within the political leadership just day
the Republican Party again the Democrats
will be reflexively contrary it doesn't
matter what the President does it's the
Republicans who are the tiebreakers and
when the Republicans begin to act in a
different way then you know something
real is taking place but I would offer
you hope the way I try to offer myself
Oh which is the sound you hear from
Washington is is not the destruction of
American institutions the sound you hear
from Washington is American institutions
standing their ground and I said
somewhere this morning and that includes
the Boy Scouts of America and the
National Football League and the
intelligence community and the FBI and
an American journalism and so on they
are holding their ground so much so that
think we've said on this panel that the
assault now has been on the institutions
because he no he he knows he cannot
succeed as long as these institutions
are viable and doing what it is they are
designed to do so it's it's game on in
in in terms of that and I frankly I
think we've come out of this at the
other end a bit purged a bit purified a
bit better at what it is we do
I hate quoting a moving plan yeah I've
ain't
I hate quoting a movie but America like
the dude will abide yeah what if we have
what about yeah I'm worried about war
war yeah so me too and the probability
of war in Northeast Asia is as high as
it's been in my professional life and
and and that is that is due to my
country stimulating the situation now to
be fair and and here comes back to maybe
the secret sauce as to how you do these
things and back back home you just can't
be reflexively negative and
just say well he did it so it must be a
bad idea a couple of years ago I said
look within our current definition of
acceptable risk is it is inevitable that
North Korea by the end of this
president's administration will have a
nuclear weapon on top of an indigenous
ICBM that can range most of North
America so the option is you want to
change your current definition of
acceptable risk which is what the
president has done that is not
irrational that may be not my policy but
it is a policy that holds together and
reflects arees a healthy response to an
external environment I think they're
handling it horribly all right but it is
the broad framework of it has a great
deal of rationality attached to it and
so the debate back home has to be on the
specifics of the policy and not turn
everything into an ad hominem attack
despite the fact that the homosapiens in
this case may deserve attack but not
turn it into an ad hominem attack as
your first reflex professor after the
financial crisis you wrote in an essay
the trust in the economy can only be
rebuilt through stronger regulation
basically strengthening institutions
it's not even possible in today's
political situation and how do we get to
from where we are to where that might be
might be a possibility well maybe the
way to begin is actually pick up where
where we just left off which is that
American institutions have done
remarkably well and in holding off the
worst of Trump and two questions that we
never asked 10 years 20 years ago what
is truth you know that was that would be
a in a philosophy department but you
wouldn't be axe again discussing what is
truth in a public forum and we are and
how do our institutions protect us
against a president who is a liar and
a racist and misogynist and and has
values different and maybe has his
finger on a button that we don't like
can they protect us so I think the good
news is that we've realized more the
fragility of our of our situation that
these are questions that we should have
been asking before I think it feeds into
a movement that was already going on
that a complex society such as ours
civil society has to take a larger role
you know we used to say government
private sector now we say government
private sector and civil society and and
civil society is very very important and
as part of the checks on that the the
for the past third of a century the
private sector corporate has been trying
to tell this
don't worry government doesn't function
but we do and we will deliver that story
is over I think and so what we do need
to do is to have civil society and
government work together and hopefully
with a lot of corporate engagement to
say you know after World War Two there a
lot of discussion in Europe with the
social partners and to say we have to
build a framework of working together as
a society and then the final comment I
want to make is the United States lives
in a global context and many of us
working working very hard not to
normalize the kind to prevent from the
normalization of the kind of behavior
that is characterized Trump and what's
been happening the Republican Party most
of the world is not in the United States
most of you know and we we are you know
globally a small part of the world
if the rest of the world comes down very
strongly and says you know you can't
live in this imaginary world you are
living in an imaginary world and that's
not truth that is going to be a play at
a very important role so I think it's
going to be very important I think it's
very important for other countries not
to give in and to say as it is and it's
uncomfortable you know everybody wants
to cooperate with the United States and
the answers we cooperate where it is but
where what you're saying is reasonable
but if you're saying something that's
unreasonable we're not going to
cooperate and I think that's an
important message that has to be given
so the world say the Paris agreement is
an example where the rest of the world
is going ahead Trump is trying to
destroy the WTO and is not allowing the
appointment of new judges to the WTO pal
panel so I think the rest of the world
is going to say we believe in a fair
rules based system we didn't have a
quite because corporate agenda but we
believe in that and we are not going to
allow the United States to destroy it
and if you're not going to play game
that's your problem we're going to go
ahead with these institutions with or
without the United States even even with
mature Western democracies the channel
of communication intelligence to
intelligence service has become greatly
enriched over the last 12 months because
these are institutions in both societies
that are generally fact-based I think
people have to step up when that Muslim
Batso Muslim ban where banned travel
from so many countries that you said
earlier fed to the worst propaganda of
the worst extremists you know what
neutralized that millions maybe tens of
thousands of Americans went to the
airports and said this is not who we are
and that was on so many screens that was
on social media I think we can no longer
just also let the institutions it's the
we'll stepping up and saying this is not
who we are
I think undermined the damage that
wrongheaded banded to a great degree
because the world looked and said oh
they're just like us they have a bad
government but they're they're good
people there and I think it's time for
everybody who's concerned about truth
was concerned about facts is concerned
about living a world together
we can't just outsource it to our
governments anybody else we have to step
up as people too so I think that's a
perfect place to stop we should see this
moment as a as a wake-up call basically
that's the takeaway thank you so much
[Applause]